in luhansk over Christmas Russia has
continued its assault on Ukraine's
civilian infrastructure but no matter
how cruel or how much loss of life
accompanies it Russia has singularly
failed to break the will of the
Ukrainian people or change the policy of
its leaders
we continue to closely monitor how
Russia's long-range strike campaign will
involve as it eats deeper into the
Strategic reserves of its own modern
missiles it is notable that Russia are
now using the forced labor of convicts
to manufacture Weaponry Ukraine however
continues using its internationally
provided long-range artillery to
successful effect
Mr Speaker throughout the war Russia has
managed to lose
to lose significant numbers of generals
and commanding officers but last week's
announcement that their commander in
Ukraine General Sergey savikin had been
unceremoniously bypassed with Chief of
the general staff General garazimov
personally taking over field command is
certainly significant
it is the visible tip of an iceberg of
factionalism within the Russian command
Putin apparently remains bullish and
with garasimos deference the president
never in doubt we now would expect a
trend back towards a Russian offensive
no matter how much loss of life
accompanies it Mr Speaker in 2023 there
is no loss of momentum from the
International Community quite the
opposite
President Putin believed the West would
get tired bored and fragment
Ukraine has continued to fight and far
from fragmenting the West is
accelerating its efforts
the United States has invested
approximately 24.2 billion dollars in
support for Ukraine since the beginning
of Russia's Invasion on the 24th of
February last year it has delivered
thousands of anti-aircraft and
anti-armor systems and has recently
stepped up that support delivering
Patriot air defense battery Munitions
and 45 refurbished t-72 Bravo tanks as
well as donating 50 Bradley infantry
fighting vehicles to assist with the
counter-offensive
we also welcome the decision of the
French government to provide Ukraine
with the amx10 light highly mobile tank
and this has been used oh very recently
in reconnaissance missions by the French
army and was deployed as recently as a
Barcade mission in West Africa
Mr Speaker important as these
contributions are in and of themselves
what matters more is they represent part
of an international effort that
collectively conveys a false multiplier
effect
none of this is happening unilaterally
no one is doing this on their own
soon I shall be announcing the first
round of bids to the Joint of the joint
chair Danish UK international fund for
Ukraine and I'm grateful for Sweden over
the festive period for adding to the pot
of money donated that now in concludes
Sweden Denmark Norway Netherlands
Iceland Lithuania and others have
donated to that fund
meanwhile Russia isolated without such
support has now lost over 1600 Main
battle tanks in Ukraine since the start
of the invasion but if we're to continue
helping Ukraine to ease the upper hand
in the next phase of conflict we must
accelerate our Collective efforts
diplomatically economically and
militarily to keep the pressure on Putin
in December I told the house that I was
developing options to respond to
Russia's continued aggression in a
calibrated and determined manner
today I can announce the most
significant package of combat power to
date to accelerate Ukrainian success
this includes a squadron of Challenger 2
tanks with armored recovery and repair
vehicles
we will donate as-90 guns to Ukraine
this compromises a batch comprises a
battery of eight guns at high Readiness
and two further batteries at varying
states of readiness this donation will
not impact our existing as90 commitment
in Estonia
hundreds more armored and protected
Vehicles will also be sent including
bulldog
a maneuver support package including
Minefield breaching and bridging
capabilities worth 28 million pounds and
dozens more uncrewed aerial systems
worth 20 million to support Ukrainian
artillery
another 100 000 artillery round on top
of a hundred thousand rounds already
delivered
hundreds more sophisticated missiles
including gmrs Rockets star streak air
defense and medium range air defense
missiles
an equipment's a poor package of spares
to refurbish up to 100 Ukrainian tanks
and infantry fighting vehicles
while the tanks in the as-90s will come
from our stocks along with their
Associated ammunition as significant
significant number of the other
donations are being purchased from the
open market or from supportive
third-party countries
today's package is an important increase
to Ukraine's capabilities
it means they can go from existing to
expelling Russian forces from Ukrainian
soil
President Putin cannot win but is
equally certain he can continue
inflicting this wanton violence and
human suffering into his forces are
ejected from their defensive positions
and expelled from the country
that requires a new level support the
combat power only achieved by
combinations of main battle tank
squadrons operating alongside divisional
artillery groups and further deep
Precision fires enabling targeting of
Russian Logistics and command nodes at
greater distance
Mr Speaker we'll be the first country to
donate Western main battle tanks and we
will be bringing a further Squadron of
our own Challenger tanks to higher
Readiness in place of the squadron's
scent
even as we give Challenger two tanks I
shall at the same time be reviewing the
number of Challenger 3 conversions to
consider the weather the lessons of
Ukraine suggests that we need a larger
tank Fleet
we will also build on the Army's
modernization program
Pace specifically on artillery I'm
accelerating the mobile fires program so
instead of delivering in the 2030s it
will do this earlier this decade
I've also directed that subject to
commercial negotiation and in interim
artillery capability is to be delivered
after discussion of the United States
and our European allies it is hoped that
the example set by the French and us
will allow those countries holding
leopards tanks to donate as well
I know there are a number of countries
wanting to do the same
no one is going it alone Mr Speaker as I
have said
Mr Speaker it's worth reiterating why we
are doing this
because in 2023 the International
Community will not let Russia wait it
out while inflicting terrible suffering
on Ukrainian civilians the International
Community recognizes that equipping
Ukraine to push Russia out of its
territory is as important as equipping
them to defend them what they already
have
this week dozens of Nations will meet in
Ramstein Germany to progress further
donations and international coordination
the Kremlin will be in no doubt that we
are resolved to stand by Ukraine in her
fight
doubling down on the success of our
basic training in Ukrainian military in
2022 in the United Kingdom we are also
now increasing this number this year to
a further 20 000. Canada Denmark Finland
Sweden Lithuania New Zealand and the
Netherlands have already joined this
effort and I'm pleased to say we are now
going to joined by a group of Australian
military to train in this country as
well leaving their summer to join our
winter brave souls our decision today is
a calibrated response to Russia's
growing aggression and indiscriminate
bombing the Kremlin must recognize that
it is their behavior that is solidifying
the international resolve and despite
the propaganda Ukraine and her partners
are focused on the defense of Ukraine
none of the international support is an
attack on Russia or NATO orchestrated
aggression let alone a proxy war
at its heart it is about helping Ukraine
defend itself upholding international
law and restoring that country's
sovereignty we believe that in 2023
increased supplies improved training and
strengthening diplomatic resolve will
enable Ukraine to be successful against
Russia's poorly LED and now badly
equipped Armed Forces
from the outset President Putin believed
his forces would be welcome with open
arms that ukrainians wouldn't fight and
that Western support would crumble
he has been proved wrong on all counts
today's package will help accelerate the
conclusion of Putin's occupation and all
its brutality and ensure that in 2023
and Beyond if necessary Ukraine retained
its momentum supported by the
International Community that has
determined more than ever that Putin's
illegal and unprovoked Invasion will
fail
Senator Secretary of State John Healy
thank you Mr Speaker I welcome the
defense secretary statement and thank
him for advanced sight of it 2023 will
indeed be the decisive year in this war
in Ukraine and the most decisive moment
is now now when Ukraine has the Tactical
and morale advantage over Russia now
when Ukraine needs more combined
military Firepower to break the
battlefield Deadlock
as the NATO Secretary General said
yesterday it is important that we
provide Ukraine with the weapons it
needs to win
that's why this first package of UK
military assistance for 2023 with tanks
artillery infantry Vehicles ammunition
and missiles has Labor's fullest support
Challenger 2 is a world-class tank and
it can help Ukraine retake lost ground
and limit the cost in Ukrainian lives
so we're now sending 14. how many tanks
does Ukraine need for a successful
counter-offensive
are the 14 challenges currently in
active service or in storage
when will they be delivered into the
field in Ukraine
what combat engineering Vehicles will be
delivered to support these tanks will
any UK forces Personnel be deployed into
Ukraine with these vehicles
and the integrated review cut Challenger
tanks from 227 to 148 so I welcome the
defense secretary's review of Challenger
3 numbers when will he announce the
results of this review and is he
reviewing other Army cuts
Mr Speaker the Armed Forces Minister
Tommy in a parliamentary answer last
week that Challenger 2 training takes 33
days for gunners 46 days for drivers in
85 days for crew commanders the defense
secretary made no mention this afternoon
of Challenger training will the UK
provide training alongside the tanks and
how long will the training for Ukrainian
troops be
Mr Speaker president zielinski has
confirmed The Wider importance of this
UK military package saying at the
weekend this will not only strengthen us
on the battlefield he said but also send
the right signal to other partners and
the defense secretary today said he
hopes that this UK military aid will
help unlock more coordinated support
from other nations so I like him welcome
similar moves already announced by other
NATO nations in recent days particularly
the US and France but can I ask him how
many of the 14 leopard using nations may
provide these tanks now to Ukraine what
more does he expect from allies at the
Ramstein meeting on Friday
and it's been five months now since he
announced the international fund when
indeed will allocations be made
now the Prime Minister has talked at the
weekend about seeing a surge in global
Military Support for Ukraine how's the
defense secretary going to ensure a
continuing surge in the UK Military
Support what more can Ukraine expect
from the UK
because Mr Speaker you know when the
defense secretary knows I've argued for
months that ministers must move Beyond
ad hoc announcements and set out a full
2023 action plan for military economic
and diplomatic support a case the
defense secretary has fully accepted
because this will help give Ukraine
confidence and future supplies it'll
help gear up our own industry it'll
encourage allies to do more and it will
make clear that things will get worse
not better for Russia
so Mr Speaker one of the clear lessons
from the last year in Ukraine is that
Nations need to have large Reserve
stocks of certain weapons and ammunition
or the ability to produce them quickly
the UK has neither
and we are still moving too slowly to
replace the weapons donated to Ukraine
or find new wartime ways of making
weapons more rapidly and more cheaply
now there was no mention in the
Secretary of State's statement this
afternoon about replenishing UK
stockpiles or a new industry plan can he
update the house on the action he's
taking
finally Mr Speaker and importantly
he said today's military package means
Ukraine can go from resisting to
expelling Russian forces from Ukrainian
soil will he confirm that this now is
the UK's strategic aim for Ukraine
serious day thank you Mr Speaker and if
you indulge me there's lots of questions
and I will do my best to to answer them
all I'm grateful to the right honorable
member and for his party's support which
as he said has been ongoing and enduring
throughout this whole process and I
believe it's what allows the UK to be
prominent in Standing Tall for
international human rights and defending
Ukraine
um he asked The Honorable right I'm
going to ask what level of support
Ukraine will need such as in scale and
and if he will uh indulge me I can't be
too specific otherwise I don't want to
set out uh to our Russians uh government
exactly uh the inadequacies or strengths
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces but it is
it is safe to say that the ukrainians
will require an ongoing commitment that
grows to the size of Divisions uh in in
its Armed Forces but also in the last
obviously a year nearly what we have
seen is Ukraine grow its own Army to
have significantly hundreds of thousands
of men and women underarms now equipped
not only with Western Equipment but also
captured or refurbished former Soviet or
Russian equipment the Polish government
themselves are donated over 200 t-72
tanks for example so the key here for
all of us is that in the next phase to
make sure we help them train and combine
all of those weapon systems in a way
that can deliver a combined arms effect
in a mobile manner to deliver an
offensive that is required or offenses
that are required to achieve the goal of
expelling and I'll come to his final
point in that that it is the UK's
government position that Putin's
Invasion fails and that Ukraine restores
its Sovereign territory and we will do
what all we can do to help achieve that
and that is this this package is part of
that and if I was to say that obviously
the challenges should be viewed
alongside the 50 Bradleys from the
United States but those are the
ingredients effectively of your battle
group with divisional level fires of of
either as 90s or other 155 iritzers the
14 tanks that represent the Squadron and
indeed 50 Bradleys would be roughly an
armored infantry battle group so so what
we're trying to do is in the next step
take a Ukrainian military whose history
has been in Soviet methods and not only
have we provide them with Western
Equipment but also Western know-how and
the training will be delivered first of
all and I'll answer this question uh
almost immediately it will start uh with
ukrainians both in the UK but also
training in the field so to speak in
either neighboring countries or in
countries such as Germany where we saw
uh the artillery train with the Dutch I
think at the beginning of this process
so training will be administered
supported both in the UK and elsewhere
in Europe to these Ukrainian forces with
the us being in the lead of much of that
formation training which is incredibly
important and supportive of the United
States to do so there'll be no UK forces
deployed in this process in Ukraine and
as I've said earlier that is because our
job is to help Ukraine defend itself and
and we can do that from neighbor or
other countries
um yes I I know the training cycle I
once was a trooper in the Scots of
guards in 1988 and I think I started my
time in a Chieftain tank which I think
you'll be lucky to see in a museum these
days but nevertheless
um I think what the ukrainians have
showed us even in their basic and other
specialist training is when you are
determined and you're wanting to go back
and Fight for Your Country their their
work ethos their hours they put in is
quite extraordinary and I'm very
confident that in one level they'll soon
be showing us the way in how to fight uh
this equipment
um
uh he references on one of the army Cuts
look in
I would I've come to this dispatchables
new occasions and admitted how well for
our armies equipment programs have been
in the past and how behind and out of
date they have been which is why we've
committed over 24 billion pounds of
investment into their equipment the
Army's equipment alone over the next 10
years deep fires I've said I'm bringing
forward recce getting Ajax back on track
ISR capability uh tanks Challenger 3 and
indeed the boxer Fleet plus many other
investments into the army it is
incredibly important I take it seriously
and I know the right on the gentleman
does too and we have to deliver an army
that can stand shoulder shoulders peers
never mind it's enemy and I think that
is important uh to say so on the area of
the leopard a coalition I think is there
calling themselves it has been reported
that obviously Poland is very keen to
donate some leopard as is Finland uh who
have expressed all of this currently
relies on the German government's
decisions not only whether the Germans
will supply their own leopards but
whether or not they'll give permissions
for others I would urge my German
colleagues to do that these tanks are
not offensive when they are used for
defensive methods you know there's a
debate in Germany at the moment about
whether a tank is an offensive weapon or
a defensive weapon well depends what
you're using it for if you're using it
to defend your country I would wager
that it is a defensive weapon system
secondly we are not on our own this is a
joint International Coalition and I know
there have been concerns in the German
political body that they don't want to
go alone while they're not alone and I
think the conference in Ramstein will
show that and the French you know I I
pay tribute to the French's commitment
to put in those tanks at Christmas time
and you know we are obviously joining
alongside them so I think but they are
the key to unlocking the leopard we'll
do a weekend to help that well the
international fund the answer is
imminently and when I mean imminently
next couple of
I shall announce it we had 27 billion
dollars worth of bids I think for a fund
that's reached 500 million and as I said
I'm very grateful for the Swedish
donation uh very recently towards that
fund and we intend to keep growing it
but I want to make sure that the fund is
spent in a sustainable way it's not a
it's not a it's not a a petty cash or a
cash fund or a slush fund where you just
go and buy something I want to invest in
things like production and Supply chains
because what is going to be key is
whether you're maintaining tanks or
artillery supplies you need an active
production line and that goes to his
very last Point uh Madam Dr speaker
which was uh being too slow to place
orders one of the reasons it has taken
time to place orders as he knows is
there is no supply chain sometimes and
you have to wait supply chain to be
either reinvested in or redeveloped or
indeed found again new suppliers before
you'll even get a price for the taxpayer
or indeed a contract delivered and that
that's what happened with the end law as
much as we would love to have placed the
order on the next day some of that
supply chain was 15 years old and had to
find some new suppliers then we got a
prize then we got some Partners Sweden
and US placed an order and by doing so
we managed to reinvigorate that supply
chain and hopefully more jobs with it
okay
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
this conflict is not going to end
anytime soon uh Putin is moving his
country to a war footing preparing for a
spring offensive So tactically speaking
finally Syria seeing some serious NATO
standard tracked Hardware being gifted
to Ukraine it was very much welcome
indeed and it's another example of the
UK leading ever pushing the envelope of
international support for Ukraine
but as other nations follow our lead
maintaining so many NATO variants of
vehicles and Equipment of Tanks apts
artillery pieces as well is Not
Practical in the long term
could the UK consider leading Again by
establishing a western funded Ukrainian
operated weapons Factory and assembly
line in eastern Poland so Ukraine can
become self-sufficient in procuring and
replenishing the military kit and
Munitions it needs for its own long-term
security without fear of the facility
being targeted by Russia
and his suggestion is absolutely uh
correct he is also right to make at the
point that for all of this gifting
unless there is a supply chain or indeed
sustainability package behind it uh then
when these vehicles run out or indeed in
in the case of artillery the barrels are
worn out they'll just become junk on the
battlefield and it's really important
that we think that way and that's why
with the Challenger three Challenger two
sorry donations will be putting in some
recovery vehicles with them and there's
a lot of thought going on right now
about exactly sustainability of that
supply chain and that slightly ties into
the international fund I'm looking for
an intelligent application for that fund
to stimulate just that on his point
about Ukraine it's how Ukraine have
shown itself to be incredibly successful
at either reverse engineering what
they've captured from Russia or indeed
uh just uh designing and developing
their own they opened a production line
of 155 shells I think recently or one
five two and they're now manufactured
training within their own country but I
will also say that we're going to get to
the same way he wants to which is I'll
use things like the international fund
or Kindred in order to fund those Supply
chains over the border and if Ukraine
approaches us with ideas for
transferring the IP for them for us to
make it for them or for them to make it
here or anywhere else I'll be very open
to doing that
person didn't yeah thank you madam
Deputy speaker and I welcome the detail
on the substance of the Secretary of
State's statement and I believe moreover
that the timing is very welcome closing
in as we are on the first anniversary of
the outrageous attack on Ukraine by
Putin and his forces last February we
must all of us regardless of our
political allegiances or differences in
other areas of politics stand up for the
International
rules-based System the rights of
sovereignty and the values of
self-determination where these are under
attack not simply at the outset of
conflict Madam Deputy speaker when
hackles are raised and outraged peaked
but now as we endure almost a year of
the effects of this conflict on these
shows in our homes in our industry and
wider resources as we continue to
witness Russia's hybrid Terror heaped
upon the people of Ukraine now is the
time to double down on the waste support
and commitment to Ukraine to defend
yourself against it against this
aggression and time to leave Putin in no
doubt that the West resolve politically
and in every other respect is there for
Ukraine to see this the distance I'd
like to know at three things Madame
Deputy speaker the Secretary of State
said on the 12th of December that you
wouldn't pursue sending redundant UK
Warrior infantry fighting vehicles to
Ukraine due to it being a tracked
vehicle weighing 28 tons and the
logistical tail that comes with these
vehicles so what has changed in a month
to allow him now to send a squadron of
68-ton challenge attacks with a very
much more complex Logistics and support
burden to go along with them can the
Secretary of State also set output the
duration between this announcement and
these Challenger twos having operational
effect within the Ukraine battle space
and given that European and NATO Nations
must doubtless follow this development
with similar donations of leopard two
tanks as a secretary of state prepared
not just to review the numbers of
Challenger 3 but whether Challenger 3
will be the right solution for the UK
going forward at all when we see
Challenger leper 2 going Toe to Toe with
the same periodiversity will see very
much clearer then which is the better
tank yeah
I'm always happy to keep under review uh
the um
you know the number of tanks and what we
have one of the lessons Ukraine is
however that
modern or not so modern tank if it
unless it's properly protected supported
either by counter drone capability
electronic warfare or indeed a proper
wrap then it can become incredibly
vulnerable it can go from you know the
lion on the on the Savannah to suddenly
a very vulnerable thing and so you you
know when you look at the finite amount
of money we would all have in government
how much do you make a perfectly formed
battle group or how much do you take a
risk the Russians took a risk on the
road to kievan that is where we are but
the difference between the warrior and
the challenge obviously is different
vehicle but secondly as I referenced
earlier the 50 Bradley the United States
vehicles are in a better probably
condition than our Warriors but secondly
these challenges are designed to
complement those and hopefully we will
be training together uh with with the
Challenger and the Bradley and to
interoperate uh secondly there are
issues with the warrior Fleet obviously
I'm happy to constantly look at that I I
won't rule it out but for now taking 12
tanks as opposed to what we'd probably
have to be 40 odd Warrior to make it a
sort of company size level I think I
would prefer to focus on the as90s and
indeed the Challenger tanks to make that
difference
so we're in Duncan Smith I don't know
Deputy speaker and I welcome the
statement from my right-handled friend
can I say it with the member for
Bradford South I had the privilege just
before Christmas of working south of
Hakeem with a British charity in
Siobhan's trust feeding thousands of
dispossessed ukrainians but while there
I was able to talk to a lot of the
Iranian military two things I want to
congratulate my writable friend because
the one thing they were saying was they
were very very disappointed in Germany's
failure to give permission for the
leopard tanks to be sent to them as
originally arranged and they now believe
that of course this decision by
himachi's government will help unlock
that the second point was that though I
visited the military Hospital in Hakeem
which is shelled by the way two or three
times a week Devastation is appalling
but they did ask me for some things that
are not offensive ones number one they
really desperately need more armored
ambulances because they say that the
experience is terrible about them
getting wounded quickly back to the
hospital was number two was that they
have a very great shortage of
paramilitary paramedics and they need
they need that very much as well and the
third area that they were keen on and
this is something that's shocking is
that the number of Ukrainian military
committing suicide now as a result of
Battlefield stress is astonishing and
they desperately desperately need help
and they did ask that the U.S and the UK
who have experience in Afghanistan Iraq
Etc could help by sending some people
over to help train in those mental
health practices it would be really
helpful Secretary of State uh can I
thank my right-home friend and I would
have say to follow up with him his
experience with respond to trust I think
uh it's easy to forget uh that there are
lots and lots and lots of ukrainians
suffering either post-conflict through
the suicide or indeed just ordinary
individuals and uh you know the tragedy
is nine months ten months in people get
slightly immune to what they see on the
media and the Telly and social media
from what is really violence and
destruction of of a staggering scale uh
my honor right from around the minister
for personal and Veterans who just said
to me that the Surgeon General is going
to visit soon to see what more we can do
to help those individuals especially
suffering uh from the acute mental
health challenges they have on Armored
ambulances I know there's been some
donations already some of which has been
also done by uh private donations I
think a colleague of ours on this house
Madam speaker from Yorkshire approached
me about a company that I think had
donated some Armada it says I in the
announcement I noticed we've sent some
bulldogs for people as old as me that's
actually got a 4-3-2
um I think they gave it a new coat of
paint called a bulldog but but
fundamentally um uh they have ambulance
variants so I'll see if they are
included in in that as well I can write
honorable gentlemen with the details of
medical support and uh on the German the
Germans about him never speaking look we
shouldn't forget they have actually done
a huge amount of donations and and well
it's probably the best sport of the
media of the Day in the UK it always you
know pursue them they have actually
delivered
mt70s gmrs the same as us they they've
made they are one of the biggest
contributors uh to the Ukraine fight uh
and uh you know I think they should give
them credit where credit's due and so
you know I'm grateful for that I just
hope that on the leopards they will
unlock if they won't do it they'll
unlock other nations to do so
Derek twig
Factory state for what he's doing and
support is giving to Ukraine
um basically we've got to do what it
takes to ensure that Ukraine win this
war that Putin absolutely understands
there'll be no weakening on the western
side in support for Ukraine but it is a
war of attrition at the moment as well
and it's very very important that it's
clear the support that we will be giving
to ukrainians is ongoing I'm done into
strategic way and while I welcome the
the challenges they needed these many
months ago and we simply that piecemeal
giving bits of help to the I'm not in
any way under and we're not in the the
amount that's been given so far and it
needs a much more to you can approach to
in terms of ramping up our production
when the West as a whole in terms of
support they're brought on to replenish
our own supplies as the my right more
offenders at Shadow secretary of state
so and can I say this final thing
Twitter didn't mention is Belarus are we
giving a really clear message to Belarus
because the reports coming through today
about them training their joint training
exercises with the Russians that any any
infringement upon Upon A Ukrainian soil
from Belarus will meet with the serious
sequences
yes on Belarus
um it's been interesting that Putin's
loyalist Ally seems to still not yet
have committed his forces himself uh in
it and I think that slightly speaks
volumes about I think the neighbors are
sensing quite how weak Putin in one
sense has become when the bully isn't
able to bully in the playground I think
you start to see consequences Kazakhstan
and elsewhere
um look we we have seen Russians move
units up to Belarus and then back out
again we saw them recently doing
training which I think what he's
referring to in that unit but absolutely
we engage with Belarus and I think
Belarus understands uh the consequences
of off what further action would mean to
its status in relation to Russia and
indeed Ukraine and I think Ukraine does
speak to Belarus as well as does
President Putin but um no good would
come off a extra edition of Belarus
Madam just be just on the piece Mill uh
claim I understand that um but I also
come and balance the calibration that
we're trying to achieve with uh what we
do now and um it is important that we do
it as a coalition together uh the
amazing thing about the Ukrainian uh
support is actually it is huge amounts
of bilateral Arrangements it isn't as
Russia would like to accuse us of a NATO
orchestrated event it isn't a proxy war
it isn't an attack on Russia or Russia
phobia it is fundamentally like-minded
countries recognizing that that the
wrong that's gone on in that country
Through The Invasion coming together and
they would like us to believe all those
other narratives it's not it's defending
a country defend itself and what's great
is how many countries around the world
agree with upholding human rights and
international law and want to come
together to help
I warmly welcome the Secretary of
State's statement this afternoon not
least as the ukrainians are now clearly
fighting for our freedom as well as for
their own
but after what one might call a bruising
encounter battle last week between his
departmental Witnesses and the defense
committee over the achingly slow
re-equipment of our own British Army I
welcome his sense of urgency on that too
but could he specifically declare some
of our
AFV programs such as boxer the
Challenger 3 upgrade and indeed the
mobile fires platform as urgent
operational requirements which would
mean that we effectively cut all the
usual procurement bureaucracy and bring
those vital systems into Service as soon
as possible
well my wife of a friend uh is as Keen
as I am on uh changing the history when
it comes to procurement and and it is it
is remarkable that when it comes to
assisting Ukraine high speeding we can
get things into the field or indeed how
we can adapt things
or or how manufacturers seem to
magically adapt things and there are
lessons in there uh I'd already started
the process earlier of of accelerating
the channel 3 Program last year I didn't
want to take the Gap in the middle of
the decade but of course when you
accelerate you take risks but
nevertheless I think that is important I
will definitely look at a suggestion of
course the one elephant in the room on
the suggestion of accelerating is Her
Majesty's treasury you would have to
reprofile the budget and of course as
the time of the IR approaches I shall
engage with my right on from the charts
Hillary Ben
thank you very much indeed Madden Deputy
speaker night after night
the Russians continue to fire missiles
that the Ukrainian civilian population
we saw the weekend
the attack on the residential Block in
denipro has so far claimed at least 20
lives
just before Christmas the United States
announced that it would provide the
Patriot missile system to Ukraine what
assessment has the defense secretary
made of the impact that will have on
Ukraine's ability to defend itself
against these missiles and what further
capability could Ukraine use in order to
try and further mitigate the effect of
these frequent attacks which are trying
to destabilize the country and cut off
the energy Supply
observation about the powerful and
enduring impact of these horrendous
attacks
attack there is The Echoes of the V1 and
the V2 campaign with little intelligence
targeting by the looks of things and an
attempt to terrify people across the
Ukraine firstly the way that I think it
has improved the defense of the airspace
and despite Russia's claim the vast
proportions still of these Munitions
don't make it through the tragedy is
some do and we of course would all like
to work to make it a hundred percent uh
uh certain the Patriot missile is
obviously a long range into ballistic
missile that effectively
Interceptor and is probably more use at
some stages against some of the more
sophisticated uavs or missiles that
could be fired or are fired occasionally
and of course we'd all be worried about
the next Iranian ballistic muscles if
they were put in the other thing we've
edited with volume is what the
ukrainians need they need volume of the
short range the medium range and they
need volume of ammunition to deal with
some of this whole race range of UAV
that's the real key is that you can have
the most sophisticated launchers in the
world if you can't afford the missiles
you soon run out as Russia is now at
finding uh itself volume and better
coordination and better targeting the
United Kingdom has helped and I said in
the house last time that we used our
knowledge to advise them and help them
on how to layer their air defense better
and to prioritize uh the the
infrastructure they need to defend
because there are so many targets that
the Russians are firing at they need to
start with the priority list and they're
doing that now it is having an effect
but that's why we're now seeing Russia
being more indiscriminate just throwing
it at anything that's less predictable
and therefore harder to defend
Wendy Morton thank you madam Deputy
speaker I'd like to thank my right
honorable friend for his statement today
and the welcome news of the latest UK
package of support including
um the challenge of two tanks and
Bulldog but and also the support from
from other International uh Partners
such as the US and France but can he
reassure us that he will he plus
um colleagues in the fcdo and the
Diplomatic routes that we have will
continue to do all they can to make sure
that we that we we bring on board
maximum support from from other
countries and bad through the bilateral
relationships that we have because that
is going to be so crucial to maximize
the force multiplier effect that he
referred to in his statement earlier
both I think in terms of military and
humanitarian
so yes um
right all my friends right you know I I
come to this house obviously talk about
defense and weaponry and and lethal aid
but there are other pillars in this
there is the Diplomatic pillar it's
incredibly important the economic pillar
through sanctions uh and that is a very
very important track uh to engage on and
I know some of that work isn't made
public but but some of it is and Russia
is currently seeing its economy damaged
by these sanctions and they won't be
moved anytime soon and it is important
to recognize that there is a diplomatic
track there's a diplomatic track open to
President Putin should he wish to end
this senseless violence and Invasion and
seek to remove his forces from Ukraine
of course there's a track open this is
not a a one-way thing and and we will
work very hard on it but absolutely the
military is hand in hand diplomacy and
the economy and we need to make sure we
keep that up whether that's at the U.N
whether it's bilaterally or whether it's
with a new 4 as well
thank you madam Deputy speaker and the
liberal Democrats would like to very
much welcome the Secretary of State's
statements today
and building on his uh exposition of the
economic diplomatic and Military levers
because I just also add that
communication levers are really key we
know that Russian propaganda wishes to
twist international support for Ukraine
into a narrative that suggests that
somehow this is a war of self-defense
with Russia fighting against nato in
self-defense how is the Secretary of
State working with cabinet colleagues
and with people who work on strategic
Communications in the mod to counter
that narrative
I I think it's incredibly important we
country he's right and you know he'll
have heard me say twice from this batch
box what this is not it isn't an attack
on Russia it's not a proxy war it's not
a NATO orchestrated uh aggression in any
way at all it is fundamentally about
helping Ukraine defend itself we make
sure we message that throughout
government but also we make sure that we
we message that as much as possible into
Russia so Russians understand the
consequences of President Putin's uh you
know badly thought through Special
Operation and it's also why I think what
we're seeing is uh fractures in the
Russian general command and indeed the
political leaders who themselves know
that nothing is going to plan but it is
important and it's important far further
across the globe when there are grain
shortages in Africa or people can't
afford it it's not because of the West
it's because of what Russia has done in
the Black Sea and Russia is doing the
ports of Mario Paul and places like that
that's why Africans are finding it hard
to get grain and pain more for it
because of Russia
so Julian in Lewis thank you madam
Deputy speaker my right honorable friend
describes the Russian Armed Forces as
poorly LED and badly equipped what
assessment does he make of the Wagner
group that seems to be operating
independently and with allegedly more
successful effect and am I right in
thinking that an organization that pulls
criminals out of jail and sends them
into battle is surely operating well
outside the law of armed conflict
a moment of a friend makes a really
important point about vodka I think for
a long time Wagner has operated outside
the rules of any law I think that has
been its selling point in Africa and
Libya and Mali that you know pay for us
with contracts or diamonds or whatever
and that you know there are no rules and
they have been observed on numerous
occasions engaged in war crimes and
events but their proximity to the
Kremlin of course doesn't fool anyone
that this is somehow some Universe
unilateral purely commercial uh
operation currently we think they're
using two-thirds of their fourth around
back mootin area of two-thirds convicts
taken from prisons uh they're suffering
approximately two-thirds casualty rates
so it's not a good deal if you're a
convict uh in the Wagner group but it's
also a a very worrying reflection if I
was uh General garazimov I'd be asking
myself why I am outwitted outperformed
by a bunch of uh mercenaries
and Rivals by the looks of things uh in
in Moscow and what does it say about the
Russian army that the it takes a bunch
of mercenaries uh as they would see it
uh to get some traction however I
wouldn't believe uh Wagner's propaganda
either there isn't much traction there
is only death either at the hands of
their their paid commanders or indeed at
the hands of their own men to their own
selves you've seen the social media
videos where they executed a convict of
their own using a sledgehammer
so Chris Bryant thank you madam Deputy
chair and the deputy speaker sorry the
this war hasn't been going on for 10
months it's been going on for nine years
and we do need to make sure that Putin
ultimately loses but it's not just about
military military Solutions it's also
about economic ones rebuilding
reconstructing and frankly protecting
many ukrainians from the freezing cold
this winter
um and and being able to put food on the
table for their children over the years
to come at the moment we've guaranteed
something like three billion pounds
worth of financial support but there's
an easier solution there's more than 23
billion pounds worth of Russian assets
sitting in British Banks why don't we
seize them and send them to Ukraine
well uh the right honorable gentlemen
first of all makes the most important
point
even before the 24th of February Russia
had killed 18
000 18
000 Ukrainian troops since 2014. there
wasn't a month or a week that went by on
that border where they weren't shot so
when we say to people oh it might
escalate or it might be a war ukrainians
often look at us in sort of where have
you been for the last decade and it's
very sobering if you go to Kiev to the
memorial and most of those plaques are
way before February 201
on the building and a refurbishment and
the support to the refugees this is
where I think Germany needs to get the
credit Germany and Poland have hosted
tens of thousands of thousands of
ukrainians it is putting lots of money
into
Aid support for Ukraine and is making a
significant difference and I think that
is I've often said Madam Deputy speaker
that the strength of Alliance of 30 40
people is we can move at different
speeds and nevertheless with that and on
his point of Russia
as the former criminal Finance Minister
and security minister I would be quite
interested to know why we can't
thank you my
girl can I join others in thanking my
lifetime profender for a statement today
and our ongoing support to Ukraine I
want to follow up on what my honorable
friend just said about the Wagner group
we heard last week how the brutal attack
on the Tiny Town of solidar has
literally left the fields littered with
the corpses of men and my right on all
phone the defense secretary has has just
agreed from the dispatch box that this
is an organization that has been guilty
of many war crimes in many parts of the
world not least last year and Mali also
had a cir to his list it's been put to
me that if the Wagner group was
prescribed as a terrorist organization
this could make it much more difficult
for godson to recruit into this
organization so can I urge my right on
Fender defense secretary to work with
the Home Secretary and the foreign
secretary to make sure that we're
Gathering all the evidence we have
against the vagler group and taking
every single action we could to try to
curtail their activities including
prescribing them as a terrorist
organizer
look I'm very happy to take that away
and look at exactly that um although I'm
not sure they recruit at all anymore I
think they just pile people in
Rachel mascal thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I thank the defense
secretary for giving a full exposition
of the military aid which he is
providing it's so important that
ukrainians have the most advanced
systems at their disposal however we
also know that Putin is targeting the
energy infrastructure across Ukraine I
wonder if he could set out a little bit
more about what we're doing to help
protect that and also rebuild it for the
future State yes first of all uh
generators we are providing generators
in the International Community is I'm
very happy to write to The Honorable
lady with the exact numbers of
generators in other words to to mitigate
the effect of of these strikes at the
same time as I said uh to her honorable
that The Honorable lady's friend sitting
behind her um that we have helped with
the coordination and the priorities of
that and at the same time a number of
international partners are helping with
the training and support of those brave
men and women who are going out there to
fix those infrastructures almost
immediately they are hit and taken down
and making more and more people able to
look after the electricity
infrastructure but it is incredibly
important but of course Putin will know
that weather improves hopefully in the
spring and then some of his impacts will
be lessened so I think that's one of the
other reasons we're seeing an increase
currently of strike time
so Bernard Jenkins
how many
defense reviews can I write honorable
friend recall that have been preceded by
fashionable commentators decrying the
idea that main battle tanks had any
utility in Modern Warfare and now that
that has been disproved and my right
honorable friend has made a hugely
significant move this week by agreeing
to send main battle tanks in the support
of Ukraine's defense will he consider
sending more tanks if these tanks prove
to be effective and can be effectively
supported and can we use this as an
opportunity to bolster and strengthen
the supply chain and manufacture of our
next generation of Tanks now that he has
proved to the treasury that they are not
a waste of money
well I read from my honorable friend
well first of all the good thing about
the Challenger 3 supply chain it's in
Stockport and Telford is where we are
doing the work on the Challenger threes
and I'm delighted it's near where we're
also doing the boxes so we are
reinvigorating the land systems supply
chain the honest points about tanks
no one was ever writing that we should
get rid of tanks and indeed I hopefully
my defense review was a bit better than
the defense review that said there was
no use for a machine gun after the
Japanese Russian war or indeed the brave
Admiral who said that submarines had
absolutely no utility uh in the lead up
so most of them being sunk and I think
the first and fourth by a German U-Boat
so um I don't think we said that but I
do think yes it has showed that armor is
important especially if not just from
the basic protection of hand grenades
dropped by uavs but it also shows that
without your armor properly protected in
a 360 way you are also incredibly
vulnerable to handheld anti-tank weapons
that if you notice the British enlar and
the U.S Javelin are successfully
remodeling hundreds and hundreds of
t-72s from very short distance so we
have to have proper protection both
electronically but also in the layered
defense that we need in this modern
Battlefield
Toby Perkins thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker whatever the manifold
differences that we have in this place
it's good that people across Ukraine and
Russia will have heard once again the
Resolute message from this place on all
sides of the house we support the
Secretary of State's move to donate
those Challenger tanks and that we're
absolutely Resolute that Putin's
aggression must fail now the Secretary
of State said in his statement uh that
the Challenger tank donation will help
not only uh to resist the Russians but
also to expel them we've heard Ukrainian
officials and NATO Secretary General
saying that Russia is planning a major
offensive this spring so can the
Secretary of State tell us what more the
UK can do to set up broad support Beyond
tanks to support the ukrainians to repel
that major Russian aggression I'm
grateful for honorable gentleman's
comments and look the I recognize that
14 tanks is not going to change the
course of history but it is also about
trying to be that Force multiplier
putting the four Gene tanks to the 50
Bradleys and the divisional level of
deep long-range artillery and hopefully
unlocking a leopard tanks across Europe
if we can do that then I think we can
raise a significant mass that is
important to enable uh that fire and
maneuver that maneuver Warfare that will
be needed to push uh Russia out uh of
course Russia has planned for an
offensive of the grazimov being
reappointed effectively he'll be able to
make the same mistakes twice that he did
the first time uh but nevertheless yes
they're not giving up but nor are we I
noticed uh social media in Russia
commenting that our decision to send
Challenger tanks would change nothing
yeah he's right he won't change nothing
Ukraine
continue to win and Russia will continue
to lose James sanderlin
speaker can I please thank the defense
secretary for his statement which I
welcome and also to commend him and his
department for the superb work that's
been undertaken right now to help defend
Ukraine
as he knows armor is logistically very
challenging so could I please ask him to
confirm how it's going to be deployed
whether risks to the supply chain can be
mitigated at all
and also whether we have a plan for how
we're going to turn our own land
equipment availability back from red to
Green
right on the last point and I'm grateful
my friend for the question oh no the
first point of course to be honest about
the state of our armored Fleet our land
systems I I you know I am you know I've
been pretty brutal in the house here
about how actually the state of it is
not acceptable and it hasn't been in a
good state for over a decade if not much
longer and how they've got away with
that how it's happened I do not know so
we're not honest we can't start that
process we're putting the 24 billion
pounds to modernize or change that Fleet
as much as possible and he's right on
the supply chain uh not only are we well
supported by some of the neighboring
states and thinking that through the
Slovak intervene very forward-leaning
about helping support the t-72s or
refurbishing but also in making sure
that we are doing an assessment of our
supply chain to see what is needed it is
timely because obviously with our
Challenger three upgrade we are needing
a supply chain to be reinvigorated and
that's what we'll work on but I'm very
happy to meet with him to discuss it
further
Jim Shannon Davis speaker can I
congratulate the Secretary of State and
our UK government on following through
the commitments to support Ukraine the
provision of the 14 Challenger two tanks
and other donations as evidence today uh
in this statement
with the potential of a Russian defense
of clearly more tanks are needed more of
the missile defenses are also critical
to enabling ukrainians to get on their
feet and to survive and to end this
conflict with Russia once and for all
will uh the United Kingdom of grip
written on shown the will and the
physical commitment can I make a special
appealed please uh for the at the
missile defenses so that
ukrainians can keep the lights on
uh hit their homes save lives and along
with the generators and Engineering help
is there the Ukraine can rebuild itself
yes we're committed to that and today I
announced a more High Velocity missile
and indeed low uh velocity of the other
missiles both made in Northern Ireland
that are doing a fantastic job
Richard
Craig Madam Deputy speaker the defense
secretary has laid out very clearly the
reasons why the government is providing
a squadron of 14 Challenger tanks to
help the defense of Ukraine and he's
also implied that issues of supply chain
spares ammo and training have all been
carefully considered but my right
honorable friend will also accept I
think that the biggest contribution the
challenges may play is the Diplomatic
one of helping him unlock solid
commitments by the 14 leopard using
Nations could I ride on and confirm what
he thinks the impact of any commitments
at that meeting in Germany might be
combined with the Challenger tanks on
the Russian Armed Forces leaders
well I I would hope that the Russian
Armed Forces recognize over the
Christmas break that uh their their best
a bet is to cut and run or to indeed
stop and withdraw and I think that is
Dawning on a significant number of
commanders the problem is the commanders
aren't around long enough to be able to
pull the levers to make a difference
with sort of Beacon being replaced by
garazimov uh you know maybe gerasimoth
has been put in Prime position to be the
full guy in three months time like all
his predecessors on that and maybe that
is the cunning Kremlin plan I I don't
know but it is important that we
recognize that uh somehow Russia needs
to come to its senses about what is
happening the special operation has
failed and is failing and the best thing
they can do is leave and then we will
try and find a way forward
McCartney thank you madam Deputy speaker
sadly we've seen more evidence this
weekend of Putin's barbaric targeting of
Civilian infrastructure in Ukraine
particularly with the residential blocks
in denipro and that's why I welcome
today's announcement on the Challenger 2
tanks can their Secretary State just
confirm that we're not going this alone
and on behalf of my Ukrainian community
in Huddersfield and comb Valley who are
so proud of our steadfast support for
Ukraine can the Secretary of State also
confirm we're continuing with our
donations as he said of generators
humanitarian Sport and medical supplies
for the Ukrainian people
yeah those supplies are going to get
even more important and I'll do
everything I can to stimulate more of
that and if uh honorable and right
honorable members of their house have uh
considered you know companies and their
constituency who are Keen or indeed are
facing barriers to being able to do that
then please make sure that I'm made
aware and we will see what we can do
look we just have to do everything in
the next few months to stop this
targeting of the cities in an
infrastructure help them see that
through help them defeat it but you know
targeting civilian blocks and danipa
does nothing but commit murder
talk to Matthew the removal of Russian
forces from cities such as Kirsten has
led some civilians to return to their
homes even though the areas are
contaminated with explosive weapons last
week as chairman of the all-party
Parliamentary group on explosive weapons
I met a Ukrainian MP who's seeking to
put together a civil demining program
can the Secretary of State ensure that
his officials will be available to meet
with myselves and other interested
parties so that we may be able to put
together a program to help people as
they return to conflict in an
appropriate and timely manner
look I'm delighted to meet with him or
indeed my officials with it he'll notice
within the statement I announced 28
million pounds towards Minefield uh
breaching bridging capabilities combat
engineering which is desperately needed
I thank the Secretary of State
um for answering me um for the statement
on a point of order uh Jim McMahon
thank you madam this is speaker on a
point of order last week the High Court
ruled against the Dartmoor National Park
Authority who sought to protect the
right of free access for wild camping
this is a significant backward step
seemingly putting the financial
interests of one person above the
fundamental access rights which have
been hard fought for and provided for in
law by this house
Madam Mr Speaker this goes beyond that
more and could potentially put at risk
rights and protections for national
parks including the right to roam can I
ask have you had any notice from the
Secretary of State of her intention to
make a statement to the house and if not
can you advise a house on how better